autre performance ce soir sera assurée
par christophe alévêque que nous
recevons à l'occasion de la sortie de
son dvd l'enregistrement de son
spectacle debout au casino de paris
alors à savoir que vous pouvez retrouver
list of alévêque en tournée le 19
décembre à nice le 16 janvier à lyon et
le 19 janvier à montceau ça devrait vous
émouvoir ces pays de votre enfance à
montceau-les-mines à montceau les mines
c'est exactement là où j'ai quand même
vécu 20 ans alors vous avez là je trouve
la gentillesse en même temps il a été de
rendre hommage à laurent ruquier pour
lui dire que grâce à lui vous travaillez
depuis dix ans d'ailleurs vous êtes avec
lui à la télévision et à la radio c'est
normal mais moi je suis comme c'est le
cepac avec le lancer avec les potes avec
tout le monde
moi j'ai toujours été quelqu'un j'ai la
reconnaissance du ventre donc laurent et
fait sa carrière grâce à l'équipe qu'il
a autour de lui et nous il nous a aidés
lui personnellement je pense que c'est
un échange de bons de bons procédés
alors parmi un petit peu de ce spectacle
alors des sketches à ces envois de man
show un univers musical qui vient se
promener comme ça dans le spectacle qui
est pas plaquer moi j'ai monté un groupe
de musique donc les droits des musiciens
le groupe o il ya trois des musiciens
qui viennent comme ça et qui vont qui
viennent sur scène sans jamais
s'installer dans les têtes de turc de l
évêque parce que c'est là par les
américains là
la religion c'est à dire c'est nous et
dans le spectacle mais je vais vraiment
chercher les gens je fais pas de je cite
pas de noms dans les spectacles
évidemment il y en a qui se
reconnaissent pire maintenant avec les
élections bon je commence à avoir des
plages d'improvisation assez sévères non
mais ça veut dire que plus qu'avant vous
pour aujourd'hui
l'humoriste est nécessaire un petit peu
pour pointer le doigt sur tout ce qui va
mal pour comment dire moi j'essaie de ne
pas être un moraliste je suis c'est sûr
que c'est insupportable ni un dictateur
de penser puisqu'il y en a plein les
les journaux et
beaucoup d'émissions simplement
j'essaye de regarder les choses comme
moi j'ai le temps parce que c'est mon
métier par l'autre bout de la lorgnette
voilà donc je fais le métier du fonds
comme il était fait depuis très
longtemps et j'ai sans compromission et
en profitant totalement de la liberté
qui m'est donné et c'est ce que les gens
veulent ils veulent que sur scène voir
quelqu'un qui te parle qui dans tout ce
que je dis je peux raconter des
conneries ou juliette d'hypocrisie la
mauvaise foi mais au moins je crève
l'abcès ps concernant public ya des
soirs où il ya des des sketches on sent
qu'on est un petit peu aller trop loin
et puis après on retient un peu les
chevaux ça les gens me connaissent
maintenant donc franchement je peux je
peux aller très très pardonne tout non
seulement ils pardonnent tout mais je
pense qu'ils en redemandent en demandant
à nous aussi on va en demander on va
demander donc un extrait de ce spectacle
est pas facile si vous me demandez ouais
bah oui alors vous avez choisi un
extrait qui s'appelle juste un petit
passage sur les religions qui est plus
que je vais beaucoup plus faire tout
comme un texte qu comme d'accord donc
christophe alévêque un petit extrait de
son spectacle s'est inscrite sur la
vérité je parle de la vérité dans le
spectacle je veux que tout le monde nous
manquons est victime de manipulation de
propagande en permanence et alors les
copains les animaux enfin tout ça est
alors les religions les religions donc
ce set c'était chienlit qui est de
retour évidemment
qu'est ce qu'une religion sinon une
vaste rumeurs persistantes
c'est à dire que des bus pas de papiers
pas de crayon pas de sténo riad pote est
un peu devant la caméra dans l'ensemble
dans l'ensemble mais d'un autre côté un
macaque t'a plu
c'est vrai il me rappelle mon fils et ma
ville un peu sur foire au 6e c'est ça
hein quoi la caméra y en a une et donc
pas de papiers pas de crayon pas de
ténor rien donc là il ya un envoyé divin
donc accompagné d'un engin euros comme
ça et qui répètent les paroles d'un dieu
le père que personne à part lui n'a
entendu
bon alors déjà au début ses limites
après une poignée de témoins de première
bourre les apôtres qui répète ce qu'ils
ont entendu mais de tête
ensuite est-ce qu'on va appeler des gens
d'église qui interprètent les paroles
des apôtres mais toujours après ta les
croyants 1
c'est le cas de dire qu' au lieu de
croire en eux répètent les parents des
gens dans les paroles des gens d'église
au conte moyens c'est à dire tout et
comme il est con et moyens va à son tour
répéter les paroles des croyants qui
répétaient les paroles des gens d'église
qui répétaient les paroles des apôtres
qui est répéter les paroles de leur
voyage qui répéter les paroles de son
pater
si ça c'est pas la définition d'une
rumeur
imaginez donc un seul instant à curer
dépressif ou un apôtre alcoolique au
milieu de la chaîne et en ça commence
avec eux tu ne tueras point
après tu ne tueras point ton voisin
après tu ne tueras point ton voisin sauf
si l'un plus grands jardins et sa fille
lié avec dieu est avec nous on peut
envahir l'irak
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]